[Musique étrangère]
Je continue de réécrire les vieux trucs, et si
et les hypothèses n'ont pas vraiment d'importance
ici et est-ce que rien n'a d'importance dans ce
monde si Tessa n'est pas là ?
J'ai progressé dans le nouveau
livre, tout le monde meurt d'envie de le voir et  J'ai
peur de ne pas pouvoir continuer à décourager les gens, je
ne peux pas précipiter la grandeur, n'est-ce pas, je peux quand
j'aurai une
avance en dollars à
Noël, elle a demandé après toi, elle a
déménagé à Lisbonne Lisbonne
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais, d'accord, fais amende honorable,
tu dois  pars,
j'aimerais vraiment pouvoir y retourner, j'ai
évolué et si toi aussi, je
sais qui tu es, tu dépends de moi,
tu vas pourrir toi-même
[Musique] j'ai
tellement peur d'échouer alors je finis par
tout gâcher à la place si  Je ne l'
avais pas, je n'aurais pas le livre mais si
je n'avais pas le livre, je l'
aurais quand même.
Je ne suis pas prêt à passer à autre chose,
tu ne parles pas seulement de nous comme ça,
imagine vivre un autre moment.  sur cette
Terre sans toi à mes côtés teste
[Musique]
sans toi il n'y a
que moi
brisé
perdu sous l'amour
c'est facile de croire que notre capacité à aimer
est finie surtout quand ton cœur est
brisé Croyez-le ou pas lentement vous
guérirez
vous ne savez jamais comment  tu as de la chance de
passer le reste de ta vie avec l'
autre moitié de toi-même
jusqu'à ce que tu doives passer ta vie
sans eux
[Musique]